former White House aide Omarosa
Manigault Newman says she will not be
intimidated or bullied by President
Trump she says she's been interviewed
for Robert Miller's Russia investigation
and is ready to give him any recording
she made Ouija Jang is at the White
House with new allegations from the
former staffer we took good morning good
morning bianna Omarosa is making a new
claim the president Trump knew
beforehand that WikiLeaks was going to
release Hillary Clinton's emails during
the 2016 campaign his personal attorney
Rudy Giuliani says Omarosa is lying it's
just one of many damning things she has
said this week about the president who
says she is violating a confidentiality
agreement there's a lot of corruption
that went on both in the campaign and in
the White House aide Omarosa Manigault
Newman says she's ready to provide
special counsel Robert Muller whatever
he needs to expose wrongdoing at the
Trump campaign and the White House I'm
gonna blow the whistle on all of it
hours earlier the president's team filed
an arbitration against Omarosa for a
breach of her 2016 confidentiality
agreement with the Trump campaign I
don't believe that I violated but I'm
gonna leave that to the lawyers that
he's trying to silence me so what is he
trying to hide Omarosa is in the middle
of a media blitz to promote her new book
unhinged published by an imprint of
Simon & Schuster a division of CBS in it
she paints president Trump as a racist
who's mentally unfit to run the country
to support her claims
Omarosa has released recordings she
secretly made inside the White House and
on the campaign trail in one of the
recordings staffers are heard
strategizing on ways to deal with the
potential fallout of an alleged tape
where mr. Trump uses the n-word multiple
times on Tuesday press secretary Sarah
sander said she wasn't sure if the
president had used the derogatory racial
slur in the past I can't guarantee
anything look I haven't been in
every single room I can tell you the
president has addressed this directly
and Sanders would not answer yesterday
whether she has signed an NDA which is
normal for staffers who have a security
clearance but sources tell CBS News that
top-level employees here in the Trump
administration who did not have a
security clearance like Omarosa did have
to sign a non-dispersive the president
or making money from their time here
several former White House
administration officials told us an
agreement like that is unheard of not
enforceable and totally outrageous Yale
right we should Jane thank you very much